[Música]
se cumple una semana de la nueva
ofensiva aérea de Rusia contra kiev al
menos ocho muertos deja una oleada de
ataques con drones kamikaze sobre la
capital ucraniana Estados Unidos Francia
y Reino Unido carga en contra Irán por
suministrar esos drones a Rusia la
República islámica lo niega
la primera ministra del Reino Unido les
pidió Perdón por su fallido plan fiscal
el gobierno de la primera anunció este
lunes La retirada de gran parte del
polémico mini presupuesto que
desencadenó una tormenta económica en el
país en medio de esta crisis tras dice
que va a terminar su mandato
Karim Benzema y Alexia putellas rey y
reina del fútbol el jugador del Real
Madrid levanta su primer balón de oro y
acaba con una sequía de 24 años para
Francia la española se consagra con su
segundo galardón consecutivo
Bienvenidos a una nueva franja
informativa aquí en France 24 Gracias
por continuar con nuestra señal Yo soy
Juan pupiales
al menos ocho personas murieron en kief
la capital ucraniana después de una
serie de ataques con drones kami casi de
fabricación iraní lanzados por Rusia el
kremlin pone el foco de sus bombardeos
así sobre la infraestructura eléctrica
en una nueva ofensiva que completa ya
una semana tanto Estados Unidos como
Reino Unido y Francia aseguran que este
suministro de drones por parte de Irán a
Moscú viola una resolución de Naciones
Unidas pero Teherán niega esta
colaboración el informe es de Marina
sardina
desde el cielo una retahíla de
bombardeos con drones kamikazes golpeó
la capital ucraniana kiev en las calles
el rugido de las sirenas columnas de
humo y el rostro del miedo
teníamos miedo porque sabemos que los
drones vuelan a menudo hacia los
apartamentos y las casas normales y yo
estaba segura de que volaría hacia
nosotros
el alcalde de la capital vital y clic
calificó a Rusia de estado terrorista
tras los ataques en niko life los
bomberos tardaron más de 5 horas en
extinguir un incendio sobre unos tanques
de almacenamiento de aceite de girasol
el ministro de defensa ruso señaló que
los aviones del kremlin destruyeron seis
depósitos de municiones ucranianas en
varios lugares durante las últimas 24
horas las fuerzas armadas de la
federación rusa continuaron realizando
ataques con armas de alta precisión y
largo alcance tanto por aire como por
mar con base en los sitios de comando
militar Comunicaciones y energía de
Ucrania todos los objetivos han sido
alcanzados este lunes la planta nuclear
de saporiya también tuvo que ser
desconectada de la red eléctrica por las
afectaciones de los bombardeos recursos
se trata de la central nuclear más
grande de Europa que pese a estar
operada por personal ucraniano es el
kremlin quien tiene el control
terroristas rusos bombardearon una vez
más subestaciones de infraestructura
crítica en el territorio controlado por
Ucrania lo que provocó el cierre de la
última línea de comunicaciones znpp de
750 kilovatios a las 3:59
Moscú intenta contrarrestar semanas de
pérdidas en el campo de batalla con una
política punitiva de daños a las
instalaciones energéticas un golpe
estratégico de cara al invierno con
graves consecuencias para la población
civil a pesar de que Vladimir Putin
había dicho la semana pasada no ver
motivos para más ataques masivos contra
Ucrania sacudirse la inestabilidad
política en Reino Unido y con ello crece
la especulación sobre el futuro de la
primera ministrarles el ministro
británico de finanzas ayer mexicana
anunció la anulación de la mayoría de
las medidas Fiscales que originaron la
desestabilización de los mercados en el
país un plan que era bandera del
gobierno conservador recordemos lo que
ha sido esta iniciativa económica
impulsada por el ejecutivo
el pasado 6 de septiembre listos asumió
con la esperanza de darle un giro
económico a Reino Unido
Confío en que juntos podemos capear la
tormenta podemos reconstruir nuestra
economía y podemos convertirnos en el
país moderno y brillante que sé que
podemos ser
una iniciativa pausada algunos días por
la muerte de la reina Isabel II
tras el Duelo tró se enfocó nuevamente
en su principal objetivo la crisis
económica a finales de septiembre de la
mano de suministro de finanzas cuasi
cuartel La Premier dio a conocer un
polémico plan económico que hizo que la
libra esterlina se desplomara a niveles
nunca vistos el punto más controvertido
tenía que ver con un nuevo impuesto para
los más ricos una medida que dividió al
partido conservador y generó una crisis
de gobierno al interior de los Story
pese a las críticas La Premier continuó
defendiendo su plan y días después
modificó parte del proyecto incluyendo
el polémico punto de impuestos para los
que más ganan
sé que el plan presentado hace solo 10
días ha causado un poco de turbulencia
lo entiendo lo entiendo estamos
escuchando y hemos escuchado
el 14 de octubre la crisis se agudiza
trous decide sacrificar a su ministro de
finanzas y pide su dimisión
hablé con él y temprano sentí muchísimo
perderlo es un gran amigo y Comparte mi
visión de poner a este país en el camino
del crecimiento
hoy le he pedido a Jeremy que se
convierte en el nuevo ministro
la rienda es económicas del país pasaron
a manos del experimentado Jeremy home
quien llegó Pisando fuerte y en Solo dos
días destrozó el plan financiero que
había sido la bandera política de Trust
en primer lugar revertiremos casi todas
las medidas Fiscales anunciadas en el
plan de crecimiento Hace tres semanas
que no han comenzado Las legislación
parlamentaria
tras el anuncio de Home la imagen de
trolls queda muy golpeada y los
fantasmas de una destitución vuelven a
la unión Street
el futbolista francés Karen benzemayla
español Alexia putellas fueron
galardonados este lunes en París con el
Balón de Oro masculino y femenino
respectivamente Benzema a sus 34 años se
convirtió en el primer francés en
llevarse este prestigioso galardón que
entrega la revista Franz fútbol desde
que lo hiciera zinedine Zidane a finales
de los años 90 veamos el informe
un trofeo esperado por el fútbol francés
desde 1998 y es finalmente Karim Benzema
quien lo ha recibido 11 veces nominado
entre los mejores jugadores desde 2008
el delantero francés completó este año
una temporada excepcional con el Real
Madrid el capitán del club español marcó
44 goles y realizó 15 pases decisivos en
todas las competiciones durante una
temporada la mejor actuación en toda su
carrera una recompensa individual que
perseguía desde hace tiempo
siempre está en mi cabeza pero cómo
hacerlo eso hay que fijarselo como una
ambición Y eso pasa por las grandes
competiciones y los grandes partidos
hoy recibe la más alta de distinción
individual del fútbol mundial y con ello
Karim Benzema desafía la historia
apodado como el niño terrible del fútbol
francés su nombre apareció en 2010 en el
caso zalla el nombre de una escort caso
del que finalmente salió absuelto cuatro
años más tarde pero en 2015 el chantaje
a su compañero de la selección francesa
Mateo Balbuena por un vídeo sexual
vuelve a manchar su carrera por este
caso fue expulsado del equipo nacional
por didida de Sam más de 6 años después
recibe una pena de un año de prisión y
75.000 euros de multa el 18 de mayo de
2021 volvió a lo grande al equipo
nacional y se reveló como un líder
indispensable para debilidades por su
parte la futbolista española Alexia
puntellas logra esta hazaña tras una
lesión que le impidió participar en la
Eurocopa femenina pero aseguró en su
discurso que pronunció en castellano
inglés y Catalán que espera volver para
tocar el balón con el que ha roto todo
tipo de retos colectivos e individuales
Manuela Cano nos cuenta más
un galardón que sabe a revancha la
futbolista catalana Alexia putellas alzó
su segundo balón de oro y vuelve a
brillar muy feliz de volver a estar aquí
muy contenta
la verdad que cuando hace un año
conseguimos ganar
el primero me propuse yo misma intentar
mejorar
pero vestida de gala y fuera de las
canchas reconoció que echa mucho de
menos sentirse futbolista no ha sido un
año fácil para putellas el 5 de Julio la
futbolista tuvo que dejar su ilusión de
disputar la Eurocopa una ruptura de
ligamentos de la rodilla la alejó del
balón que ha perseguido casi desde el
momento en que aprendió a andar
ahora empieza una nueva etapa desde que
tengo uso de razón jamás he estado más
de 5 días sin tocar un balón entrenar o
competir era y es mi pasión y será todo
un reto este proceso pero Confío en
recuperarme retomar el camino y terminar
lo que empecé
el camino comenzó en mollet del vallés
un municipio en la provincia de
Barcelona
en donde la catalana dio sus primeros
toques al balón con una calidad que la
condujo rápidamente al sabadell al
español y luego al Levante
y también abrirse paso a la selección
nacional
mientras crecía como futbolista putellas
también tuvo que enfrentarse a una
pérdida personal
en 2012 su padre falleció y ese mismo
año llegó el club de sus amores El
Fútbol Club Barcelona ese por el que
festejaban juntos cada anotación vestida
de azulgrana a la futbolista llegó al
momento cumbre de su carrera
conquistó la liga española en cinco
ocasiones y en 2021 la catalana alzó la
orejona dándole la primera Champions
League al Barcelona femenino
putellas también brillan lo individual
En la temporada 2021 y 2022 fue la
máxima goleadora de la Champions League
la tercera anotadora en la liga y la
mejor asistidora de España ahora
putellas deberá ganar uno de los
partidos más importantes de su carrera
recuperarse de su lesión y Volver al
campo de juego
cambiamos de tema en irá se cumple un
mes de las manifestaciones que
comenzaron después de que la joven
maxamín muriera bajo custodia de la
policía de la moral por presuntamente no
llevar cubriendo todo su rostro este
lunes la Unión Europea lanzó sanciones
contra 11 funcionarios iraníes y contra
varias por su papel en el fallecimiento
día Minnie y también en la represión
contra las marchas antigobernamentales
Andrés granadillo nos tiene los detalles
un mes de Furia en las calles iraníes
desatada tras la muerte de maxa Mini el
16 de septiembre Quien murió tras haber
sido detenida por la policía de la moral
por el uso inapropiado del hillab miles
piden que se ponga fin al uso del velo
islámico y que salgan del poder los
clérigos gobernantes en esta Universidad
de chahericort Corea van por una sola
persona asesinada hay otras mil detrás
las manifestaciones han sido fuertemente
reprimidas por la policía y según human
right Swatch habría más de un centenar
de Muertos incluyendo menores la Unión
Europea en respuesta emitió nuevas
sanciones contra avances funcionarios
iraníes incluido el jefe de la policía
de la moral
el consejo ha adoptado medidas
restrictivas contra 11 personas y
dirigidas a quienes están vinculados a
la muerte de maxam y la represión de
manifestantes pacíficos
pero las marchas no solo se llevan a
cabo en Irán otros países como Canadá
Francia Ecuador o Turquía se han Unido
Quiero la muerte de la República
islámica todo el mundo quiere Eso no se
trata solo del jillap no se trata solo
de las mujeres se trata del régimen
queremos que este régimen desaparezca
hay muchos problemas en mi país amo a mi
país porque iba a vivir aquí en Turquía
porque estoy aquí porque ellos son
Realmente malos
a pesar del desafío para el gobierno de
Irán por estas sanciones y las protestas
incesantes en las calles el sistema
iraní que llegó al poder tras la
revolución islámica en 1979 parece estar
lejos de ser derrocado el líder supremo
sigue acusando a Estados Unidos y a
Israel de estar detrás de un amplio
malestar social que tampoco da signos de
apaciguarse
en Estados Unidos este lunes dieron
inicio las votaciones anticipadas de
Cara a las elecciones de medio término
en el estado de Georgia dado el
presidente de acoso a los funcionarios
electorales tras la derrota de los
republicanos de este bastión conservador
muchos trabajadores han decidido dejar
sus puestos además ambos candidatos al
senado de ambas bancadas están envueltos
en sendas polémicas
con un nuevo ciclo electoral de medio
término las miradas están nuevamente
enfocadas en Georgia un estado que fue
clave para la carrera por la casa blanca
y para darle a los demócratas un
estrecho control de la cámara alta con
un aura de temor entre los trabajadores
electorales por las amenazas que
sufrieron en 2020 tras las infundadas
acusaciones de su puesto fraude
electoral de Donald Trump tras su
derrota Joe byden ganó el que había sido
el bastión republicano desde 1992 ha
sido una lucha a conseguir trabajadores
electorales en todo Georgia muchas
personas debido a los últimos ciclos no
han querido serlo Vanessa fue una de las
trabajadoras acosada y sometida a la
presión política algunos de sus
compañeros No han querido retomar sus
puestos en estos comicios ella no temo
volver
y permito que la gente mente mide así y
me quite algo que disfruto hacer ellos
tienen el poder sobre mí y si alguien
tiene poder sobre ti entonces creo que
puede hacerte cualquier cosa que quieran
lo hago para asegurarme de Que todos
tengan el derecho que tengan derecho a
votar puedan venir y hacerlo para
facilitarles el proceso para asegurarme
de que entiendan el proceso
la polémica envuelve también a los
principales candidatos en la carrera por
uno de los escaños en el senado el
conservador Walker es jugador de fútbol
americano y firme antiaportista está
acusado de haber pagado un aborto a una
de sus exparejas su rival el pastor
demócrata Rafael warnock también fue
acusado por su exmujer de violencia
machista ambos niegan las acusaciones
sabes es una elección de alto perfil
Creo que muchas de las afirmaciones del
último ciclo electoral han sido
desacreditadas así que tengo la
esperanza de que este sea un ciclo
electoral tranquilo Georgia podría
volver a tener las llaves para que los
recordatas mantengan el control del
senado en un estado donde las nuevas
leyes electorales apuntan a reducir la
participación de las minorías en el
proceso democrático
así finalizamos esta emisión informativa
aquí en la pantalla de France 24 pero
ustedes quédense tenemos actualizaciones
al minuto aquí en nuestra pantalla y
también visite nuestro sitio web France
24.com
[Música]